[Music]
the Germans differ much from these
usages for they have neither druids to
preside over sacred offices nor do they
pay great regard to sacrifices they rank
in the number of the gods those alone
whom they behold and by whose
instrumentality they are obviously
benefited namely the Sun fire and the
moon they have not heard of the other
day it is even by report their whole
life is occupied in hunting and in the
pursuits of the military art from
childhood they devote themselves to
fatigue and hardships those who have
remained chaste for the longest time
received the greatest commendation
amongst their people they think that by
this the growth is promoted by this the
physical powers are increased and the
sinews are strengthened and to have had
a knowledge of a woman before the 20th
year they reckon among the most
disgraceful acts of which matter there
is no concealment because they bathe
promiscuously in the rivers and only use
skins or small cloaks of deers hides a
large portion of the body being in
consequence naked they do not pay much
attention to agriculture and the large
portion of their food consists in milk
cheese and flesh nor has anyone a fixed
quantity of land or his own individual
limits but the magistrates and the
leading men each year apportion to the
tribes and families who have united
together as much land as and in the
place in which they think proper and the
year after compel them to remove
elsewhere for this enactment they
advance many reasons lest seduced by
long continued custom they may exchange
their ardor in the waging of war for
agriculture less they may be anxious to
acquire extensive estates and the more
powerful drive the weak of
their possessions less they construct
their houses with too great a desire to
avoid cold and heat lest the desire of
wealth spring up from which cause
divisions and discards arise and that
they may keep the common people in a
contented state of mind when each sees
his own means placed on inequality with
those of the most powerful it is the
greatest glory to the several states to
have as white deserts as possible around
them their frontiers having been laid
waste they consider this the real
evidence of their prowess that their
neighbors shall be driven out of their
lands and abandoned them and that no one
dare settle near them at the same time
they think that they shall be on that
account the more secure because they
have removed the apprehension of a
sudden incursion when a state either
repels war waged against it or wages it
against another magistrates are chosen
to preside over that war with such
authority that they have power of life
and death in peace there is no common
magistrate but the Chiefs of provinces
and Canton's administer justice and
determine controversies among their own
people robberies which are committed
beyond the boundaries of each state bear
no infamy and they are vowed that these
are committed for the purpose of
disciplining their youth and of
preventing sloth and when any of their
Chiefs has said in an assembly that he
will be their leader let those who are
willing to follow given their names they
who approve of both the enterprise and
the man arise and promised their
assistance and are applauded by the
people some of them as have not followed
him are accounted in the number of
deserters and traitors and confidence in
all matters is afterward refused them to
injure guests they regard as impious
they defend from wrong those who have
come to them for any purpose whatsoever
and esteem them inviolable to them the
houses of all are opened and maintenance
is freely supplied